of Instagram and Facebook videos and posts that claim this or that nutrient
cures cancer. What do you have to say about these clips? I'd say be very very
careful. So I'm not afraid of that. I just do not like alternative practitioners.
They might have the best part, excuse me, in the world and they're trying to help
cancer patients, you know, immensely. They're trying to give the best advice but
everybody is unique. And to say, oh, this cures cancer, I've seen Facebook posts
like that where people make up, make, create really pretty memes that say,
it tumor kills cancer in 100% or some silly thing like that. Well, the truth is
if you took a petri dish and you put cancer cells in there, you could put
evaporated water in with it, it would probably kill the cancer cells. So
it doesn't mean that evaporated water kills cancer cells or some silly
things like that. It's just to me, it's just foolishness. Everybody's physiology is
different. You got to look at the big picture. You got to treat people individually.
And I think it gives alternative practitioners a black eye, honestly, when you see
claims like that, or when you see quote-unquote nutritious make certain claims
that are just not, that are not completely honest. And I think that's, there's
danger in that. I think it gives people, you know, wrong thoughts about what's
going to help deal with their cancer or their serious disease. I see a lot of
Instagram posts like that and it's, I just unfollow those people because it's
just, I think they influence people the wrong way. Especially we live in this
world of influencers, right? Are you going to be careful who you are allowing
to influence you? The Bible is very clear that we're supposed to be careful that we
protect our mind so that we don't allow bad influencers who all sorts of that
going on. So you have to be careful with that. So no, I don't say there's not
validity in anything, but when you start making claims, then you do have to
be careful. I also have a struggle when you hear claims. And I just talked to
somebody the other day that they said they're starting to drink alkaline water
because doctors so and so said that alkaline water is the best thing. Oh my
word. It's like I've talked about this in the past lots of times. That's just
not the right thing to do. Please don't do that. You're not alkalizing your
system when you are drinking alkaline water. You're not alkalizing your system.
You're not doing anything from an oral standpoint. So it's just, it's just really
poor understanding of physiology. And that just makes me really sad.